this is a production of cornell
university
all right well thank you for coming
today my first
reaction when i was getting ready was
what a dorky title for a presentation
i have to tell you where it came about
it was a week in january
my father-in-law passed away my
mother-in-law
was failing in health and we needed to
move her
into an assisted living facility and i
got an email from neil saying i need a
seminar title
and that sounded like a good idea at the
time not having any idea where i was
going to go with it but
i think at this point i have a little
bit of a better sense
so a little bit about myself again i'm
marcia iam shively and i have this
unusual split in our department
i'm actually 50 teaching as a senior
lecturer
and 50 extension as a senior extension
associate
and i know that as a non-tenure track
faculty member i i see this as a dreamy
split because it's all education
you know it would be viewed as tough to
get tenure on but i'm really grateful
for it because
it does afford me the opportunity to
really wallow
in education and um in in a
presentation like this when i look back
over the last five years
it's always a little tricky to know
whether to go
for breadth or depth you know should i
be giving you
a sort of dog and pony show sort of so
to speak of everything i've done for the
last five years
if i were in your shoes i don't think
i'd find it that interesting
or go for a little bit more depth so i'm
actually going to try to shoot for both
today
so what i'm going to do is in four
slides i'm going to do
sort of highlights of the last five
years
four dense text heavy slides
and i won't linger on them so that i can
then go
more deeply into something that i find
interesting and hope you will as well
so bear with me while i do a quick
overview because i do think it's
important that you have a sense of
how have i spent my time in the last
five years so i'm just going to do some
highlights
and then walk away from those if any of
these intrigue you you can make a note
of it and just ask me about it at the
end of the presentation
so i'm first teaching highlights i do
teach
a university course horticulture 2010
was accepted as a university course
which is really exciting it means the
university
supports it champions it sees it as
a model of interdisciplinary excellence
and promotes it throughout the
university which has been a really
wonderful experience
i also teach a global service learning
course
cross-listed with a i iard
i co-teach with marvin pritz a
collaboration leadership
and career skills course for all of our
incoming freshmen in the plant sciences
and most recently started a new
intensive study and botanical
illustration course
i am the advisor for hortis forum
and tried to strengthen their academic
experience of that club we now have a
hoardest forum officer leadership
development class and i offer a number
of special topics courses and work with
a lot of individual
study students and have a couple of
formal internships i also
went through the process and i would i
this is a really great
project for any of you who are in
teaching and you want to go a little bit
further into it
center for teaching excellence offers
the opportunity to become a teaching
scholar
you work closely with them take
workshops you do a project
they observe your teaching and i
recently completed that
i've also started a horticulture minor
with a focus on the botanical arts i'll
be talking a little bit more about that
i'm really proud of my assessments i
brought a number of them over here i
have some rubrics and
other approaches to assessing things
like project work
writing participation
put a lot of effort into it and actually
now work with people throughout the
university often referred by folks in
the center for
engaged learning and research to work
with them to develop similar rubrics
for their courses actually including don
we
recently had a meeting i'm was one of
the inaugural engaged learning and
research faculty fellows
and was awarded a kaplan family
distinguished faculty fellowship
in 2009 and i've received two teaching
awards
in terms of extension highlights we've
spent quite a bit of time
trying to be more culturally responsive
and i hired a student who worked with me
to interview a number of extension
educators that culminated in
a spanish language translation of one of
our
one of our online curricula we now have
a really exciting
take root cce educator enrichment
approach i've hired liz falk
she does a bulk of the workshops now
around the state
really primarily focusing on the
professional development of our
educators
received a grant to start a statewide
partnership with the new york state
library system and
also collaborated with uc davis to
create a searchable database of
garden-based learning research
and we've initiated some model gardens
small as beautiful some small model
gardens
around new york state created numerous
online curricula
including a big food systems curriculum
a youth grow youth leadership
curriculum and cultivating creativity in
the garden curriculum all
online we hosted the first youth grow
summit which was a youth leadership
summit for young people interested in
being
food systems champions and i teach a
suite of distance learning courses
two times a year i teach a suite of
three
botanical illustration courses and an
introduction
to garden design so i you know i know
that's just
a lot but i feel it's necessary to tell
you about
i'm not going to go into that in any
detail if you're interested
please ask me about it so now a little
bit more of the depth
whatever the context whether i'm
involved in teaching or extension
these are the things that are the most
important to me
i had a wonderful opportunity so to
speak about four years ago i had my
first really awful semester
it was a really awful semester and and
it gave me the chance to
try to think about why is it so bad
why am i not getting through in this
class what is it that i haven't
articulated that's important to me
so i spent a whole semester thinking
what have i not conveyed
that is really important to me and how
could i do a better job of
that and at the end of the semester
here's what i had come up with
deep learning genuine participation and
engagement
reflection community civility
and respect and creativity these are
really important to me
you'll find them all in my rubrics it's
very clear to my student that these my
students that these are important to me
too
i measure it i look for it remind people
of it
i can stand behind it and so
it was an awful semester and it was
really a wonderful semester
i'm not going to talk about any of those
above five for the remainder of the
presentation
i'd like to talk about creativity
because i spend
so much of my life wallowing in it
that i i think it's important that you
all as my colleagues
understand why that matters
why do we have somebody in our
department who is explicitly
looking at this particular thing and i'd
like to begin
uh with with some definitions for your
benefit
what is it to be creative according to
the dictionary
it is relating to or involving the
imagination
or original ideas so that's what it is
to be creative
and creativity is the ability to
transcend
traditional ideas rules patterns
relationships and the like
to create meaningful new ideas forms
methods interpretations
so it's originality progressiveness
or imagination so this is what creative
and creativity is
transcending traditional ideas original
ideas
so before we go any further and i love
this painting you can't really
appreciate it in this light i did this
in january and
on my screen it's gorgeous
i'd love to just sort of spend some time
looking at this i should have brought
into the
the original but i would have gotten off
track with that
um but i'd like to have an awkward pause
and i'm going to pause for just a moment
and ask you this question
think about your work as a researcher a
teacher
an extension specialist a student
how are you creative within the context
of your work
and what does it mean to you to be
creative certainly
every one of us in this room is not the
purview of artists
if we're not creative we're probably not
here at cornell university because it is
about
original ideas new thinking so just
pause for a moment and think about that
you may even want to write a note to
self
just you know think about any facet of
your work
and while you're thinking about that you
might also think what if anything
blocks that ability to think or act
creatively
so again just kind of hold that thought
i'm going to come back to these
questions i'll give you an opportunity
to tell me a little bit about it but
just hold that thought for now
so the way the rest of this presentation
is structured first i want to tell you
the what
of what i work on in this arena so i'm
spending a lot of time with it
and then i want to come back to that
question of you know why
maybe why it matters to you then i'll
share with you why it matters to me
and to my audience so first the what
over the past five years i put a lot of
energy into
kind of the arts based part of
horticulture we have a big
online curriculum called dig art
creating cultivating create creativity
in the garden
it's a it's a it's an avenue through to
ecological stewardship
through the creative arts
in the garden also i mentioned the art
of horticulture course i'm spending a
lot of time
guiding students in the creative process
in horticulture producing all sorts of
novel work
and this is our dean sitting with our
students out in front of the
when we had the sod sofa in front of
caldwell hall
so we do a lot in this area a lot of a
lot of
activity and energy we have this new
horticulture minor with a focus on the
botanical arts
and students are already enrolling i
have seven students signed up and i just
you know just launched it in the fall
and i'm pleased with that as a good
start because some of them
i had a ton of seniors who wanted to do
it but they just
you know they couldn't meet the
requirements for the minor
and then this distance these distance
courses that i teach to students all
over the world
i'm telling you if there's one thing i
can do that i can
stand behind and say that i do well man
i
tell you what i can teach people to draw
and paint
and work online i feel very confident
about that
most times that i teach it i have
students that surpass
me this is john perry's drawing and
graphite of a mountain laurel it took
him 20 hours and i look at that and say
i could not i don't think i could do
that at this point
so students work their way through
a series of courses that take them ever
deeper
into proficiency and technical skill
as well as the ability to portray plants
beautifully and creatively and i'm
astonished
at what they're able to produce and i'm
not kidding you
i just wrapped up a unit this weekend of
three courses
and i have a lot of students who are who
are now a lot better than i am which
is a really interesting feeling and then
and then um there is the work that just
sort of
you know it bridges teaching and
extension and everything i think a good
example is patrick doherty we brought
him here as a messenger lecturer
i collaborated with larry smart which
was so exciting we brought all this
willow into the i think a children's
garden we had a hundred people
working with this world-renowned
sculptor to produce this
just amazing piece of sculpture and it
this is like nearly chaos here's patrick
doherty right at the center of it
center of it girl scouts are running all
over the place man it was so much fun
so well i'm putting a lot of energy into
this arena you know it's taking a good
chunk of my time and i think it is
it's important to um to ask the question
why does it matter
i mean why does this matter why
should we be having in this department
someone who's putting energy into arts
based coursework and
and effort and and reflect on that and
be transparent about it i have
my thoughts about it but i'd love to
hear from you
maybe we even begin with the second
question how did you answer that earlier
question what is it to be creative
what blocks your creativity and why do
you think this work matters
and then i'm going to spend about 20
minutes telling you why i think it
matters so let's hear from some of you
i really can wait a long time
as my students know if i pause i'm
really waiting for somebody else to
speak yes
and there was that word opportunity so
it means taking an opportunity
to you know you're talking about
somewhat traditional arts approaches in
terms of creative performance or
but it could be research what is it to
be creative in your research
i'd love to hear somebody address that
yes
to be able to think outside the box and
answer these questions that
are the gaps in the research and so
sometimes that involves completely novel
thinking and designing
an approach that's never been done but
you know then you also have the it
blocks your creativity because you have
to follow what's been done before and it
has to be publishable
and so you have to you can be creative
but within those guidelines
to be innovative at the other hand
you've got some constraints
what about those of you at geneva what
would you have to say about this
steve what do you think
um
i think for me the fun of
being creative is to sort of challenge
what people believe whether it's a
grower or whether it's a fellow
horticulturalist and
this is the way we do things well ask
the question why do you do it that way
has it been tried another way
i mean and then and then develop some
some sort of a
study or a test for that you know
hypothesis that we all believe in but
nobody really knows why or
when it started wonderful thank you
and and before oh go ahead neil
stephanie said sometimes we can't really
be so creative because we're trying to
set ourselves to accomplish a specific
objective
but if there's ways that we can still be
creative in our research
like we've talked about in the past an
undergraduate student will come to me
and be interested in an independent
research project i don't have any
sort of like time and money invested in
it so we can think of something really
creative and if it fails that's
perfectly fine and it's fun and we still
learn something
in the end and more often than not it
works out and turns into something
bigger than that in the end
that point about failure i think that's
really important
one more you have an element of risk
taking an adventure
and if it doesn't then we're missing out
on an opportunity
individually as well as institutions
absolutely
i'm right there with you about risk too
in terms of why this work matters i
would like to tell you why i think
this plethora of courses and approaches
matters
and i think part of it is because it
helps open
up students to exactly what you're
talking about
they need practice and sometimes they
don't get that practice
in a traditional classroom setting so
these courses might what
my hope is in the next 20 minutes or so
that i can convince you
so to speak that this is more than
drawing a pretty picture
it's more than fun it's more than
something that's beautiful
although for me if it's beautiful alone
that you know that's that's terrific
but i i think here is i'll be real
transparent as we are
entering a new era of a plant science
school for example
i think it's even more important that
people understand that
this kind of suite of approaches it's
nested
firmly in our discipline it's not an
aside it's not an
add-on so that's how i'd like to spend
the rest of our time together
first i'd like to offer a definition of
horticulture
and just remind us that it is the art
and science of cultivating gardens or
plants depending on the
definition it's a very part of our
discipline it's right at the heart of it
it's in our definition
and i'm going to say a few words about
botanical illustration because sometimes
i think for people there's an
it's a the the botanical arts or
an arts focus equals uh botanical
illustration so it's worth mentioning
it's worth mentioning that it has a foot
that's firmly rooted in science and it
combines this kind of
analytic analytical thinking with a
conceptual approach
and its main purpose is to illustrate
and convey accurate information it's
it is a scientific exploration we're
depicting what we see
this is one of my paintings i actually
don't like to do this kind of painting
but i kind of did want to show my
students that i can since i'm teaching
it
i feel like that's probably a good idea
i tend to do work that's a little more
painterly and less accurate but have
that there to show you that i can
it also can show us information about
life cycles you can see them all
depicted in this one
illustration it can tell us about plants
and context
their habitat again it can do that
beautifully
and if you see drawing versus
photography some people might wonder
about
illustration in an era of photography
it's still really valuable
you see that illustration to the right
how it's drawing out details
that we want to see a little bit more
closely
and it's beautiful and i can't say
enough about that we do need beauty in
our lives and
and i think that is something worth
celebrating and not
pushing off to the side this is benta
king the late benta king's
work she was a botanical illustrator in
the
bailey hortonworthium and i actually use
her
her um textbook i just love the book
beautiful botanicals it's just
a wonderful book and it's perfect for my
coursework
um but frankly the other the what really
gets me excited is the more creative the
more thinking outside the box
thinking beyond a botanical illustration
this is turf work it's a big
acre more than acre sized piece of
artwork that
i produced with eight students out at
bluegrass lane designed to be viewed
from
the air as people were coming into the
airport and this was nothing short
of thrilling we got up and we had flight
time with
east hill flying club and were able to
one student
made a movie of it that's now on the web
and every time i
watch it every once in a while because i
find it so thrilling
and again collaborating with some
unlikely colleagues when it comes to
this sort of work
bill miller who put this whimsical
amazing
bulb labyrinth out at bluegrass lane i'm
was hoping he'd be here so i could tease
him about it a little bit but he's not
and you know ken mudge who really got
into teaching students about
um tree sculpture as a way to learn
about plant propagation or frank rossi
who
has become like the you know sod sofa
artist guy who
just really loves that as a way of
teaching people about horticultural
principles
why does it matter again i'm going to
the rest of the theme is about why this
matters
here at cornell university i just got an
email in the last three weeks
from it's the provost and the dean of
the college of architecture art and
planning it went to a few of us around
the university and it said
while there's a great deal of impressive
art related activity in various creative
corners of cornell
this activity has not coalesced into a
broad public sense
of the arts at this university this is
in contrast
to some of our peers which have
discovered and promoted the arts
as an important component of their
intellectual mission
it goes on to say the goal is to find a
collective and inclusive structure
that can serve to advance and highlight
the arts as a key
academic dimension of cornell and serve
more effectively
as a port of call for development
so this is really cool it's happening
right now and we're leading we're we're
in the
you know this is a part of who we are
and we're actually leading the charge
here at the university
which i'm absolutely thrilled about
if we look at that dig art curriculum
and we look at what's happening with our
extension
audiences what we're learning is that
arts based approaches to gardening to
the sciences speaks to a diversity of
learners
it makes learning meaningful it can
foster critical thinking
it develops reflective learners helps
learners to engage with important ideas
and questions
it creates an interdisciplinary and
holistic curriculum
helps students to question concepts and
make connections
makes learning visible this is one of my
favorite things
it can be used for program evaluation
assessments
for young children and you're trying to
get at what they know if you can ask
them to draw
a garden before and after a program
it's remarkable how they change we're
using
the arts as a way of understanding what
people are learning at younger ages
which is
really thrilling and then the rest of
the presentation what i'll be doing is
sharing with you
some quotes that i've pulled out from
reflective writing
what students say about what they get
out of this experience
and as melissa knows as alex knows
i don't see brian emmett here today but
we have thousands of pages of student
reflections about what they learn
and i promise you i'm not going to read
that much to you it was really hard
to crystallize it into short quotes for
this presentation
but that's what i'll be sharing with you
for the remainder
so one of the first things that we hear
and i it's one of my favorite parts of
teaching arts based approaches
is that students get new eyes because it
is fundamentally not
about learning to draw or paint it's
first about
learning to see you first have to know
what you're looking at before you can
know what to do with it
and it blows people's minds when they
start to see what's out there
all the stuff that students have been
tuning out
their whole lives suddenly comes rushing
in and it is
nothing short of amazing miraculous
wonderment really and truly one
student said perhaps the ultimate
highlight of this course
is that has developed my sense of
observation
to a new level i can't stand still
without being aware
of incredible sights i don't just see
objects
as complete and whole entities i see
textures
light lines shapes tones shadings
motion that are beautiful just as
isolated parts
and just as i take in the appreciation
of independence
i see the whole again as a synthesis of
these parts
it's almost overwhelming to be so aware
and i feel in tune with nature in a new
way
another student emailed me just this
morning and said creativity comes
from deep observation she had that line
it reminds me of this poem and i love
this poem i actually got this from tom
whitlow
and i read it often i think it's just
great it's called the three goals by
david budville
and he says the first goal is to see the
thing itself
in and for itself to see it simply
and clearly for what it is no symbolism
please
the second goal is to see each
individual thing as
unified as one with all the other
ten thousand things in this regard a
little wine helps a lot
the third goal is to grasp the first and
the second
is to see the universal and the
particular simultaneously
regarding this one call me when you get
it
and the students
in the distance courses and here on
campus get it
they see it it's like they can see the
parts in the hole all at once
i have that feeling when i'm painting
and again it's just
it's just amazing the feeling that it
gives you
a sense of curiosity whether a student
is deepening their approach to a
painting
or working with plants and learning tree
sculpture
i hear again and again that reconnecting
with a sense
of what it is to
to be curious again is something that
they feel
horticulture 2010 has put me back in
touch with the feelings that originally
caused my interest in horticulture
somehow over the past few years through
my academics and work in horticulture
i've gotten away from those feelings of
wonder and curiosity that stem
from the creation both within
horticulture and
art i'm not saying that the class
changed my perspective
rather reintroduced me to one that
played such an important role
in my life so that's something that
comes up
again and again as the tas in these
classes know
we could we have thousands of pages
about how
stepping aside using a different part of
your brain getting outside doing
whatever you're doing
helps students and others to learn to
manage stress
this is at a workshop we did with adults
at um
longwood gardens through the american
horts society and i
i had so many pages but i'll just share
this quote with you
it's the only time in my week that i'm
not stressed out
it's really kind of sad but we hear that
quite a lot
healthy risk the biggest change i would
say i've seen
in in students and adult learners
through the distance courses in the last
decade
is they're terrified of of making a
mistake their fear of failure is just
insane i think people come in and again
i think you can have a sense
in one of these courses it's easy what
can it be you're just drawing
students don't know the rules they don't
know they'll come in they know how to
study for an exam but they are so unsure
of the creative process and we take big
risks
this is gandhian grass i don't know if
you saw this it was in mann library we
projected an
image on a canvas of grass that we had
grown
it was in a big black velvet box
and we burned that image into the grass
and then it was revealed we didn't know
what we were doing we'd never done it
before it was a big risk
and it's on display in man library when
the students did this huge thing from
the air
the whole time we're saying what if what
if it's a bomb
what if we get up there and it doesn't
look like anything
it was a real thrill this is a student
who made the first grass dress
and she failed at it but we all learn
from it
this one student says
because this studio has opened the door
to creativity and more courageous
actions
i have become less hesitant in speaking
up in other classes a bit of a surprise
there
but again it's something i hear a lot of
improved mood
hey i got an improved mood from doing
this it's really well i mean why not say
that our work is fun
we're creating sod sofas and exploring
you know working with our discipline in
different ways
here we are in the lower left hand
corner we have that big
rooted installation that will be going
in down on
live slope and it's a it's a joyful
project that celebrates human well-being
and it's
in our connection to the plant world
we'll be launching that in april
realizing how important it is to take
time for what i love in this case making
something with my hands
has greatly improved my happiness i
don't think there's a person in the room
that can't relate to that a change in
attitude
and this can play out in a number of
different ways but this is one
short quote that i really liked learning
comes from trying new things
and not being perfect which is novel for
a cornell student
really not being perfect that's really
something right there
healing now here's an interesting one i
feel as if i'm getting into some tricky
terrain but i'll
back my way out of it and i'll tell you
why i do want to show you this piece
this is a color pencil from someone
from last year again way better than
anything i think i could come up with
it's just
absolutely a stunning piece of work that
you're looking at
i taught a class in recent years and
went around the room and said you know
what are you here for what do you hope
to get out of the semester
this first student who responded
indicated that they were recovering from
cancer
this is on campus here and
they were here for healing the second
student said well now that you've
admitted that
i will tell you that i took a mental
health leave and i'm back on campus and
i'm taking this class because of its
reputation for healing
they continued like that around the room
meanwhile i'm thinking oh man
i had no idea so you might be thinking
well wait a minute now is that our
responsibility here in horticulture to
offer a class that's fundamentally about
healing
you know aren't you going a bit out of
on a limb well it may not be explicitly
but we are all responsibility
responsible for the well-being of our
students and if we can do all of this
other
and have that be a reason that students
take our class
that is one big fat bonus let me tell
you
unusual application of horticultural
skills and knowledge expanding the
understandings of horticulture and what
we can do in our discipline
is another theme that comes up
here we are learning plant propagation
but we're making tree sculpture
certainly the work inside and with
fibers and dyes
you know it's just one more way that
students get to know our discipline i
often laugh about the student who said
i'm a real expert on dying she told me
this in class i said really well maybe
you should be helping me
should know the reason i'm telling you
is i wrote a 60 page paper on it
but never actually done it
so you know big expansion for her i love
this quote this is an old quote
it's from an ag ed major but i really
liked it as an agriculture education
major
i can definitely foresee doing this type
of activity in the future they were
referring to building assad sofa
i think high school students would
really appreciate breaking away from
textbooks
and getting to use their creativity in
the construction of a project like this
the turfgrass couch not only emphasizes
art but it can also fit into a
curriculum around plant science
horticulture
business management insect pest
management and numerous other subjects
since ag-ed is about real-life problem
solving and application
i really think this type of activity
would benefit numerous students
so i'm loving how they're taking what
they're learning and stretching it
in all different directions connecting
with something larger
this is category of you know the
students who really kind of go
a little bit further out there danielle
hodgins
many of you i think maybe didn't cross
paths with her she
she jumped ship from animal science came
into
the plant sciences and produced a sod
cow
these cows letters when she had
graduated she's the one who did the
mural in the hallway
it just it was her thing you know she
ended up going on to design
school and just she launched here she
really connected with something bigger
there are a couple very brief quotes
that i really liked that i've gotten
this semester
one i feel i see the potential in the
form and everything now
in puddles and leaves and fallen
branches and rocks
another student says regarding light
most of the plants or for that matter
our river
are coated with ice or frost the
shimmery light reflected is magnificent
how do you capture it on paper maybe you
don't
maybe you just enjoy the moment for what
it is
greater confidence this sort of goes
back to that risk taking
but i love this many times at cornell we
are challenged and it feels like we
don't measure up but through the
exercises we do in studio i always leave
with a newfound sense that i
can create these different forms of
horticultural art
it's a confidence boost that i wish more
students could experience
because it can really help students stay
sane
in this stressful environment so
all of this it's not just a pretty
picture
there's so much more happening here
i i'm going to actually offer for you i
had thought about doing this and i
thought it might be a bit of a leap for
our seminar
but i do want to offer the types of
things that we actually
do in these classes to get us to change
our perspective
you know it's these are just some sample
exercises here's a negative space where
they're drawing the spaces around
the plant there's a lighting exercise
where they're moving lights all over the
place
but here's one i have up here if anyone
wants to take i have 25
copies if you want to take them home
they'll take a drawing and this was
melissa's like
oh my gosh aha moment when um
they draw the they draw it upside down
they take it like this and they draw it
like this
then they flip it over and when they do
they're amazed at how accurate they've
gotten
because they're not labeling it as
tulips
they're just drawing line so it's all
these little tricks that we can do
to make this sort of left or right brain
leap which is really
really kind of exciting
um so i'd like to conclude by um
well here's another one of these
surpasses me i just have to show you i
just got that
this one this week magnolia leaves and
graphite
it's just i mean just amazing that
somebody can do this
it looks like i don't know what it looks
like it's just an extraordinary piece
but i want to close with an excerpt from
a poem
and i think it captures our work here in
this department
it's called when death comes by mary
oliver and i'm just going to share the
last few lines
when it's over i want to say all my life
i was a bride married to amazement
i was the bridegroom taking the world
into my arms
when it is over i don't want to wonder
if i made of my life something
particular
and real i don't want to find myself
sighing
and frightened or full of argument i
don't want to end up
simply having visited this world
and you know i do think that's the cool
thing about our discipline
it is not just about being observers
it's not just visiting this world
it's about pruning and feeling and
touching and tasting and drinking
and eating and growing and it's also
about capturing in a beautiful way
all of that activity in this particular
way
so i really appreciate your
participation i want to say a few thank
yous first to craig kramer
a number of these beautiful images were
shot by him he's always there in class
he's always
available and he makes us all look good
by capturing our work in a particular
way
i want to thank lori brewer and liz falk
my closest colleagues and
cornell garden-based learning the
teaching assistants
in my courses some of you are here today
and all of you
i i'm i'm really well aware that i would
not be able to give this type of seminar
in every department
you know it is it's different it's a bit
different and i
really appreciate that you have allowed
for the growth of this type of work
here in the department and i'd like to
thank you
so do you have any questions or comments
we have a few minutes
so much of what we like to do and what
expands our minds and
makes us relaxed is actually working
with plants physically
and what you've done is taken an extra
step for you're interacting more
actively
as an artist but already that first step
is really very valuable it seems to me
and we will make sure that
as we become more and more academic that
we don't lose touch of
the taxes
thank you is that it's almost like this
gets people in i mean it's one more way
to get them in
they're touching they're feeling they're
tasting there's one assignment
and it's my favorite assignment in the
art of horticulture class
that asks students to walk across campus
looking up for one day that's it look up
just look up when you're walking across
campus and then write about it
and it's both profound and horrifying
because students will say i didn't know
that it was fall
once they start noticing the beauty of
our landscape and wondering why they
haven't looked up
they start looking at each other's faces
and really you know it's it's really a
big deal and it's against one more
entree
into noticing this incredible world of
plants around us
yes you know as somebody who
was first associated with the old
department of floriculture and
ornamental horticulture
40 years ago this year um i viewed that
department at that time
as very traditional and i find it
very encouraging particularly as we move
into this unknown horizon of the
plant science school that there is a
marsha in sheepley associated with this
department because i think that this
need and i do feel it is a need to think
creatively to think
differently is going to be essential
as we define the roles of
our unit within the larger school yeah
thank you and i but you know i think we
have to communicate it
and not let it get buried i mean and
it is easy to misunderstand
you know what what this type of work is
about you think it's just
pretty or does anybody at
geneva
yeah marsha i have a question about
what you think about photography so it
looked like you
teach primarily drawing and painting
and i even got the impression that
you were comparing drawing and painting
to photography
and and almost saying photography was
not a creative art
so i'm just wondering what you think
about the creativity involved in
photography and computer graphics and do
you incorporate that
into your teaching as well yes i do and
i really appreciate
if i i meant i didn't mean to give that
impression
i mean with that one particular slide it
showed how you can know you can do
something with one medium but not the
other but
two people in here have come in to teach
in my class
chris wayne and craig kramer to talk
about
you know the sort of basics of
photography craig
takes them through some digital
manipulations that some students have
just taken right off with
so it's actually a real foundation in
the course
and a number of students in our
horticulture a number of students in
that course
do a lot with photography as a creative
project
so thank you i'm really glad that i
would not have wanted to leave you with
that impression
you're seeing my own you know i'm using
visuals from my own
uh skill set basically showing off
paintings
and that's all that's about any other
questions
or comments yeah yeah marsha i wonder if
you could comment on
sort of some of the differences between
the you know the online course
techniques you use and the in-person
sort of stuff
online you know i have i
i online grew out of the campus work
and part of it was
when people get together in a room and
do anything creative there's
invariably the self-denigration of the
campus it's amazing
everybody thinks they're the worst one
in the class everybody's looking at what
other people are doing
it's really interesting and you know i
don't know what happens in middle school
something happens that makes people feel
really insecure about whatever it is
they're doing and it comes up again and
again
so in 2005 i thought i wonder if online
would actually be one of those
environments
in which it's better because nobody can
see
you know your work and in fact
it is in some ways especially with
adults
who don't have that fear i'm the only
one that has to see their work
they can post it if they wish so the
other the way in which it's different is
just
you imagine that you're being taught to
draw or paint or
work in charcoal or whatever it is
online
you have to really be sequential and
step wise
because i'm not there to talk to them
anna-lysa has actually taken some of the
course work you're welcome to share the
experience but i think it's just
super sequential and you do some
readings
in some of the courses you watch some
videos and then you do
do you upload your assignment and you
also submit a piece of reflective
writing every week
so i think the way it's different is
just it has to be really sequential
for people to follow clearly does that
answer your question sure
and i can comment on taking an online
one although i haven't taken it
live so i can't compare but one thing
that came to my mind was how we have to
spend so much
of our time here at cornell in the stuff
that we are good at or supposed to be
good at
or you know like the things that we have
spent time
preparing for and for me not knowing
anything about
art and going into this just the basics
just the basics
reading the book that marcia referred to
it was like oh who knew
you know just so i was reminded of
him a children's quote about the expert
mind has very few
possibilities but the beginner's mind
has lots of possibilities
and so that's part of what it did for me
thanks
any other comments or questions
there are six handouts i didn't make
tons of copies because i didn't know
everyone would want them but there are
there's
there's a participation rubric that i
just love
it defines what participation is in my
classes and there's some reflective
writing guidelines
and rubrics there's a final project
guidelines
and then there's that upside down
drawing so that does give you a little
window into that
part and i again i know that i've taken
one part of my work and bond
into a deeply but if you ever have any
other questions about
you know that first jam-packed set of
slides if you're curious about or you
see opportunities for collaboration or
something then
don't hesitate to speak up so thank you
for being attentive
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu
you